tonight fox news media analyst and host
of fox's media buzz howard kurtz
has a recap of the stormy Daniels
interview this is not a me - I was not a
victim I've never said I was a victim
stormy Daniels as expected told CBS's
Anderson Cooper that she had a one-time
sexual encounter with Donald Trump a
dozen years ago but some journalists are
saying today that the porn actress
failed to prove her other allegations
and her lawyer Michael avenatti threw
criticism on the morning shows including
the View for over hyping the 60 minutes
appearance avenatti had tweeted a
picture of a CD implying his client
might have photos or text involving
Trump but she refused to discuss that on
CBS Daniel said that back in 2011 when
she was going to tell her tale to a
magazine a man confronted her in a
parking lot and told her to leave Trump
alone forget the story and then he
leaned around and looked at my daughter
and said it's a beautiful little girl
would be a shame if something happened
to her mom but daniel says she can't
identify the man and didn't go to the
police making the account impossible for
others to verify daniel said she
accepted a $130,000 non-disclosure deal
from trump attorney Michael Kohn because
she didn't want the story to come out
and she said she later felt pressured as
recently as January into releasing
statements denying any affair as a
matter of fact the exact sentence used
was they can make your life hell in many
different ways they being I'm not
exactly sure who they were I believe it
to be Michael Cohen that speculation led
Cohen to strongly deny any involvement
in any pressure and his lawyer to send
her a cease and desist letter and today
a White House denial he's denied the
accusations that she made last night and
has been consistent in doing so she is
not and late today in California stormy
Daniels attorney expanded her legal
complaint to include presidential
attorney Michael Kohn of defamation 60
minutes scored his biggest ratings in a
decade and the Daniel's suit and
litigation by other accusers might lead
to legal complications for the president
but in the court of public opinion
the stormy sit-down didn't seem to move
the needle